En ce moment, on parle beaucoup de changements climatiques
et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de faire une vidéo sur le sujet. Le réchauffement climatique qu'on connaît aujourd'hui
on pense qu'il est largement dû aux activités humaines.
Mais dans le passé, la Terre a déjà connu des changements climatiques
et notamment une alternance de périodes de glaciation.
La dernière s'est terminée il y a seulement 12000 ans
et à son maximum, la calotte glaciaire recouvrait toute l'Europe du Nord et une bonne partie de la Grande-Bretagne.
Pire, il y a 700 millions d'années, il y a eu une énorme période de glaciation
au cours de laquelle la Terre était peut-être entièrement recouverte de glace.
[ bruit d'animal ]
Tout ça nous dit qu'il y a évidemment d'autres facteurs que l'activité humaine qui influencent le climat
et parmi ces facteurs, il y a des toutes petites variations de l'orbite de la Terre autour du Soleil.
Ces variations, on les appelle les cycles de Milankovitch
en l'honneur de l'astronome serbe qui les a calculés pour la première fois dans la première moitié du 20ème siècle.
Aujourd'hui on va voir ce que sont ces cycles astronomiques et en quoi ils peuvent influencer le climat.
[ générique ]
On va commencer doucement, la Terre tourne sur elle-même en 24h
et c'est ça qui provoque l'alternance des jours et des nuits.
Mais elle tourne aussi autour du Soleil en 365 jours et c'est ça qui provoque l'alternance des saisons.
Mais au fait, vous êtes sûrs de savoir pourquoi il y a des saisons ?
Ce n'est pas forcément si simple que ça à se représenter et il y a souvent des confusions,
alors on va s'arrêter une minute dessus.
L'orbite de la Terre autour du Soleil se fait dans un plan imaginaire qu'on appelle le "plan de l'écliptique"
et la rotation de la Terre se fait autour d'un axe imaginaire qui passe par les deux pôles.
Naïvement, on a envie de se représenter l'axe de rotation comme perpendiculaire au plan de l'écliptique,
un peu comme une toupie qui tourne sur une table.
L'axe de rotation n'est pas perpendiculaire comme ça,
il est incliné par rapport au plan de l'écliptique, d'environ 23,5°.
Et c'est ça la clé des saisons parce qu'à certains moments de l'année, comme ici,
l'hémisphère nord reçoit plus de soleil que l'hémisphère sud, c'est ce qu'on appelle l'été.
Mais six mois plus tard, c'est l'hémisphère sud qui reçoit plus de soleil que l'hémisphère nord
et c'est ça qu'on appelle l'hiver.
Donc les saisons sur terre sont dues à cet angle de 23,5° entre l'axe de rotation et le plan de l'écliptique.
Si la terre et le soleil étaient seuls dans l'univers,
l'orbite de la terre ne changerait jamais, il n'y aurait pas d'influence sur le climat.
Sauf que la Terre et le Soleil ne sont pas tout seuls, déjà, il y a la Lune qui évidemment va influencer la Terre
mais il y a aussi de bonnes grosses planètes comme Jupiter ou Saturne qui, bien qu'elles soient situées loin de nous,
vont légèrement perturber l'orbite de la Terre.
Ce sont ces petites perturbations
qu'a calculé Milankovitch.
La première de ces perturbations concerne tout simplement cet angle d'inclinaison.
Je vous ai dit qu'il était de 23,5°, mais en fait il varie au cours du temps.
Il oscille entre 22° et 24,5°, ce n'est pas grand-chose et sur cette animation, j'ai beaucoup exagéré le mouvement.
J'ai aussi beaucoup exagéré sa vitesse puisque Milankovitch a pu calculer que
l'oscillation complète prend environ 41000 ans.
Et voilà le résultat de son calcul, ici vous pouvez voir la courbe qui montre la valeur de l'angle
qui oscille au cours du dernier million d'années qui nous a précédé.
On voit la période d'oscillation de 40000 ans.
Ce mouvement périodique joue sur le climat parce qu'il joue sur l'intensité des saisons.
Si l'angle d'inclinaison était nul, il n'y aurait pas de saison et plus l'angle est élevé, plus les saisons sont marquées.
Ça ne change pas la quantité totale d'énergie solaire reçue par la Terre mais ça change sa répartition
et comme le climat est un système complexe, ça suffit à provoquer des changements climatiques.
Notamment, les périodes où les saisons sont peu marquées
vont plutôt favoriser les glaciations parce que les étés relativement doux permettent le maintien des calottes glaciaires.
La deuxième perturbation que Milankovitch a étudié, c'est ce qu'on appelle la précession.
Je vous ai dit qu'il y avait un angle entre l'axe de rotation de la Terre et le plan de l'écliptique
mais cet axe, il a aussi une direction.
En ce moment le pôle nord pointe dans la direction du Soleil
mais cette orientation, elle varie très lentement avec le temps.
Alors c'est un mouvement qui n'est pas très simple à visualiser
mais tout à l'heure, j'ai fait la comparaison du mouvement de la Terre avec celui d'une toupie
et en fait, la terre se comporte bien comme une toupie, mais une toupie à qui on aurait mis un petit choc.
Vous avez peut-être déjà vu ça; quand on perturbe une toupie, elle se met parfois à s'incliner
et à avoir un lent mouvement de rotation de son axe.
C'est ce qu'on appelle la précession
et c'est exactement ça qui se passe avec la Terre, l'axe est incliné et il subit une rotation lente.
Milankovitch a calculé le rythme de cette rotation et il a montré qu'elle se faisait avec des cycles de 20000 à 30000 ans.
Je vous ai dit qu'en ce moment, au mois de juillet, le pôle nord pointe dans la direction du Soleil
et bien dans environ 10000 ans ce sera l'inverse,
ce sera le pôle sud qui pointera vers le soleil.
A ce moment-là, le mois de juillet sera devenu la saison chaude de l'hémisphère sud
et la saison froide de l'hémisphère nord.
Dernière variation calculée par Milankovitch, l'excentricité de l'orbite.
Alors, qu'est-ce que c'est ?
On se représente souvent les planètes comme tournant en cercle autour du soleil.
Mais ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai, en général, l'orbite d'un corps autour d'un autre
ce n'est par un cercle, c'est une ellipse
et le corps autour duquel se fait la rotation n'est pas au centre mais sur un des deux foyers de l'ellipse.
La trajectoire d'une planète autour du soleil peut être plus ou moins elliptique
et on caractérise ça avec un nombre compris entre 0 et 1, qu'on appelle l'excentricité.
Quand l'excentricité est 0, la trajectoire est un vrai cercle
et ici on peut voir ce que c'est qu'une orbite avec une excentricité de 0,5 et 0,75.
Vous voyez que quand l'orbite est excentrique, une planète ne sera pas toujours à la même distance du Soleil.
L'exemple extrême, c'est celui des comètes.
La comète de Halley, par exemple, qui revient tous les 76 ans,
elle tourne autour du soleil avec une excentricité de 0,97,
c'est-à-dire une orbite elliptique extrêmement allongée.
Quand elle arrive très proche du Soleil, c'est là qu'on peut la voir,
et ensuite elle tourne autour, et repart
pour un voyage de 76 ans, loin de nous.
L'orbite de la Terre a une excentricité très faible de 0,017,
c'est-à-dire qu'elle est quasiment circulaire, vous ne faites pas une grosse bêtise si vous la dessinez en cercle.
Mais cette excentricité varie très légèrement au cours du temps, elle passe de quasiment 0 à 0,06.
Ce n'est pas grand chose, mais ça a
une légère influence sur l'intensité des saisons.
Plus l'orbite est excentrique, plus ça crée des variations dans la répartition du rayonnement solaire au cours de l'année.
L'évolution de l'excentricité est un peu compliquée mais Milankovitch l'avait calculée
et la voici sur le dernier million d'années qui nous précède.
On voit qu'elle se produit
avec des cycles d'environ 100000 ans.
Si on combine les trois perturbations calculées par Milankovitch,
on comprend que ces variations peuvent avoir une influence sur le climat terrestre
et encore une fois, ce n'est pas tellement la quantité totale d'énergie solaire reçue qui change,
c'est sa répartition, et donc l'intensité des saisons.
Donc si on croit la théorie de Milankovitch, le climat sur Terre, et notamment les périodes glaciaires,
on dû varier avec des périodes proches de celles qu'il avait calculées, c'est-à-dire 20000, 41000 et 100000 ans.
Sauf que c'est bien gentil cette théorie
mais comment on fait pour vérifier,
on n'était pas là il y a 100000 ans pour mesurer le climat ?
Et bien... on creuse.
[ générique ]
Dans le sol, on peut trouver des indices qui nous renseignent sur les climats passés.
Vous savez peut-être que les roches calcaires sont majoritairement issues de l'accumulation de coquillages
et de squelettes d'organismes marins
qui se déposaient au fond des mers.
Et bien ces coquillages sont principalement faits en carbonate de calcium CaCO3
et dans ce carbonate de calcium
il y a des traces du climat passé.
La raison, c'est que l'atome d'oxygène, comme la plupart des autres atomes, existe sous différentes formes.
Il y a notamment l'oxygène 16, c'est le plus courant, 99,8% des atomes d'oxygène
et l'oxygène 18, beaucoup plus rare, seulement 0,2%.
Et de même que le taux de carbone 14
peut nous renseigner sur l'âge d'un objet,
le taux d'oxygène 18 nous renseigne sur le climat qui régnait à l'époque où la coquille s'est formée.
Plus le taux d'oxygène 18 est élevé, plus il faisait froid et plus la calotte glaciaire était importante.
En creusant comme ça dans les roches calcaires à différents endroits et à différentes profondeurs,
on peut remonter aux climats passés.
Ce que vous voyez ici, c'est une courbe qui montre l'évolution de l'oxygène 18
et donc, en quelque sorte, l'évolution
de l'extension de la calotte glaciaire,
pour le dernier million d'années qui vient de s'écouler.
Vous voyez que cette courbe subit aussi des oscillations
et quand on analyse mathématiquement ces oscillations on constate qu'elles correspondent exactement
aux oscillations de 20000, 41000 et 100000 ans dont on vient de parler.
C'est-à-dire que dans le passé, le climat a bien varié
suivant les cycles astronomiques qu'avait calculé Milankovitch.
Le seul problème pour lui, c'est que la confirmation de sa théorie a dû attendre les années 70,
à peu près 15 ans après sa mort.
Et oui, la science, c'est parfois ingrat.
Si vous voulez voir de vos yeux ces oscillations climatiques reflétées dans la roche,
il y a quelques endroits de la Terre où on peut les observer.
Un des plus chouettes endroits pour les voir c'est en Sicile, c'est une formation qu'on appelle Scala dei Turchi,
l'Escalier des Turcs,
où on voit très bien une alternance
très régulière de strates géologiques.
Ici on voit d'autres strates du même genre, c'est toujours en Italie
mais en fait, ce genre de structures périodiques, on les retrouve à différents endroits de la planète.
Des perturbations astronomiques gravées dans la roche. C'est pas beau ça?
Il existe une autre source qui nous confirme que dans le passé,
le climat a bien varié suivant les cycles de Milankovitch.
Ce sont les carottes de glace et par exemple la célèbre carotte de Vostok en Antarctique.
Dans ces carottes, ce qui nous renseigne sur le climat passé, c'est un autre élément chimique: le deutérium.
Le deutérium est ce qu'on appelle un proxy, c'est-à-dire que ce n'est pas une mesure directe de la température
mais c'est une mesure dont on pense qu'elle est bien corrélée avec la température qui régnait à l'époque.
La courbe que vous voyez ici représente l'évolution passée du taux de deutérium dans la carotte de glace de Vostok,
comparée à la courbe de tout à l'heure sur l'évolution de l'oxygène 18 dans les sédiments calcaires.
Vous voyez que là aussi, on retrouve les périodicités de Milankovitch,
même si ça n'explique pas tout et qu'il existe certainement d'autres phénomènes en jeu.
Puisque je vous parle de la carotte de glace de Vostok, je suis obligé de mentionner autre chose.
Dans ces carottes on trouve aussi des bulles qui ont été emprisonnées à l'époque où la glace s'est formée
et ces bulles, elles nous permettent de remonter à l'atmosphère qui régnait à l'époque
et notamment au taux de CO2 dans l'atmosphère.
Et là, si je trace l'évolution de la concentration en CO2, en parallèle de l'évolution de la température,
elles sont parfaitement reliées.
Le lien entre CO2 et climat, ça ne vous rappelle rien ?
Oui, sauf que si on regarde de près,
dans les données de la carotte de Vostok,
on voit que l'augmentation de CO2
suit toujours l'augmentation de température,
elle se produit environ 800 ans après.
Ça veut dire que pour ce qui s'est passé dans le passé,
ça n'est pas l'augmentation de CO2 qui a été à l'origine de l'augmentation de température.
De toute façon on l'a dit, les changements climatiques, leur origine ce sont les cycles de Milankovitch.
Ces deux courbes, vous pouvez les retrouver notamment dans le documentaire de Al Gore
sur le changement climatique, vous savez, "Une vérité qui dérange".
Il a toute une mise en scène assez spectaculaire et il sous-entend que le parallélisme de ses courbes
montre l'influence du CO2 sur le climat.
C'est évidemment un mauvais argument puisque dans le cas de la carotte de Vostok,
au départ, la causalité est dans l'autre sens;
c'est l'augmentation de température
qui a initié l'augmentation de CO2.
Je lui en veux d'avoir raconté ça comme ça et d'avoir utilisé ces données de la carotte de Vostok
pour soi-disant prouver que le CO2 était à l'origine du réchauffement climatique qu'on connaît aujourd'hui,
parce que même si on peut dire que c'était pour la bonne cause,
c'est un argument qui est scientifiquement incorrect.
Evidemment les climato-sceptiques ont retourné le truc à leur avantage en disant,
vous voyez bien, ce n'est pas l'augmentation de CO2 qui provoque l'augmentation de température, c'est inverse.
Oui, sauf qu'en fait, l'un n'empêche pas l'autre.
On peut avoir une augmentation de température qui provoque une augmentation de CO2;
c'est ce qu'on voit dans la carotte de Vostok, même si on ne comprend pas forcément très bien quel est le mécanisme
et à son tour, l'augmentation de CO2 peut provoquer une augmentation de température;
c'est le principe de l'effet de serre.
Au total, on a ce qu'on appelle une rétroaction positive, c'est-à-dire un phénomène qui s'auto-amplifie.
Alors heureusement, ce qu'on voit malgré tout dans les données du passé,
c'est que le climat sur Terre n'a pas dégénéré en un réchauffement sans fin.
Ça veut dire qu'il existe peut-être des rétroactions négatives qui vont venir tempérer le phénomène
et ça veut dire aussi que les cycles astronomiques sont suffisamment forts
pour venir contrer ces rétroactions positives.
Enfin, ça prend quand même des milliers d'années.
Dans tous les cas, le climat, c'est complexe et ce n'est pas parce qu'on ne comprend pas tout
qu'il faut forcément foncer dans le mur.
Pour ceux qui voudraient en savoir plus, je les renvoie à ma vidéo sur le réchauffement climatique.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo,
pour ceux qui voudraient en savoir plus, comme souvent, j'ai écrit un billet de blog
dans lequel je donne pas mal de détails supplémentaires sur les cycles de Milankovitch
l'oxygène 18 et puis un certain nombre de problèmes qui ne sont pas résolus aujourd'hui sur les liens entre
les glaciations, le climat et les cycles astronomiques.
Comme toujours, n'hésitez pas à partager cette vidéo si elle vous a plu pour m'aider à faire connaître la chaîne.
Vous pouvez retrouvez les actus
de la chaîne sur Facebook, Twitter
et vous pouvez aussi me soutenir sur Tipeee, merci beaucoup à tous ceux qui me soutiennent.
Comme c'est l'été, je vais prendre un peu de vacances donc il y aura un peu moins de vidéos pendant les prochaines semaines.
J'essaierai quand même de vous en poster une ou deux sous un format un petit peu plus léger
et puis dans tous les cas, on se retrouve à la rentrée
et je peux déjà vous annoncer le sujet de la vidéo de la rentrée, ça sera la gravité quantique à boucles.
Merci, à bientôt.